Tito's 18, lives in Los Angeles, lean and handsome and dark with a bear claw tattooed onto each cheek. And when he talks about his life thus far, he says he just didn't have a choice about certain things.
Tito今年18岁，住在洛杉矶，身材瘦削，长相英俊，肤色黝黑，双颊各纹着一个熊爪纹身。当谈到他迄今为止的生活时，他说自己对某些事情别无选择。
Basically, when I was locked up in juvenile detention I was there for a year and I really believe that if you locked up a year just with a whole bunch of guys, it really can mess with your mental stage. Because I act all hard. I act like a dude. Most likely I dressed like a guy. I tried to do everything like a guy. Play basketball. But deep inside, these real males can really know that. It's just an act. It's like really, you're a girl, but you're acting like a dude.
基本上，当我在少年拘留所被关了一年的时候，我真的相信，如果你和一大群男人关在一起一年，这真的会扰乱你的精神状态。因为我表现得很强硬。我表现得像个男人。多数时候我穿得像个男人。我试着像男人一样做所有事。打篮球。但内心深处，这些真正的男人其实能看出来。这只是表演。真的，你是个女孩，但你在装男人。
It can be very, very, very frustrating and confusing when you are around a whole bunch of males. Because what starts to happen when you're around other males, it's like the deep side of you, the female part's trying to come out, and just try to say something. But deep inside, you're pushing that person back down. It's like the egg will crack and the female is becoming birthed. I know it sounds very freaky, but this is totally real.
当你被一大群男性包围时，这会非常、非常、非常令人沮丧和困惑。因为当你和别的男人在一起时，你内心深处，女性的那一面就会试图显露出来，试图说点什么。但内心深处，你又把那个人压了回去。这就像蛋壳会裂开，女性特质正在破茧而出。我知道这听起来很诡异，但这完全是真实的。
If you're trying to figure out who you are, it's funny what can inspire you. What can be helpful and give you strength. Tito, for example, is an Eminem fan. The night Eminem performed at the Grammy's, drunk protesters, gay protesters, who called him homophobic and misogynist. Tito was at a party with gay kids and bisexual kids and transsexual kids. Kids who are actually born as boys but live as girls, who were all watching the Grammy's on TV and cheering for Eminem. Tito explains it this way.
如果你正试图弄清楚自己是谁，那么能启发你的东西会很有趣。什么东西能提供帮助并给你力量。以Tito为例，他是Eminem的粉丝。在Eminem出席格莱美奖的那天晚上，喝醉的抗议者，同性恋抗议者，称他为恐同者和厌女者。Tito当时正和一些同性恋、双性恋和变性人的孩子在派对上。这些孩子天生是男孩，但以女孩的身份生活，他们都在电视上看格莱美奖，并为Eminem欢呼。Tito是这样解释的。
Here's this white guy, Eminem, who somehow felt that part of black culture was just inside him, and decided that he would rap like a black guy. And ended up able to pass in that world.
你看，这个白人家伙，Eminem，他以某种方式感觉黑人文化的一部分就在他心里，并决定他要像个黑人一样说唱。最后居然在那个世界里通行无阻。
Transgender people, it's the same way. It's a boy that feels like a woman inside. And want to be free to go ahead and explore that. So they want to dress like a girl and acting like girl. It's in the same category for somebody that feels black inside. I feel so. I'm Caucasian, but I feel black inside, and I want to explore my side. And I think if Eminem can do it, anybody can. I mean, transgender should too.
变性人也是一样。那是一个内心感觉像女人的男孩。并想要自由地继续探索这一点。所以他们想穿得像女孩，表现得像女孩。这和那些内心感觉是黑人的人属于同一范畴。我就有这种感觉。我是白人，但我内心感觉自己是黑人，我想探索我这一面。而且我认为如果Eminem能做到，任何人都能做到。我的意思是，变性人也应该可以。
There's a deep part of American culture, which is all about the idea that you can make yourself into anyone. How many of our movies are about the idea that I'm going to be a star? I'm going to sing, dance, take Wall Street by storm. Own this crazy town. See my name in lights. Someday be a gangster. Someday be a real boy. Someday get to Washington and make a difference. Someday leave my uncle's farm in Tatooine and become a Jedi knight like my father. Well, today on our program, stories of people who felt this very American call to be something that they were not, and who then willed it to happen. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
美国文化中有一部分深深扎根于一种观念，即你可以把自己变成任何人。我们有多少部电影是关于“我要成为明星”这个想法的？我要唱歌、跳舞、席卷华尔街。拥有这座疯狂的城市。让我的名字闪耀在灯光下。有一天成为黑帮老大。有一天成为一个真正的男孩。有一天去华盛顿做出改变。有一天离开叔叔在塔图因的农场，像我父亲一样成为绝地武士。好吧，今天我们的节目，讲述了一些人感到这种非常美国的召唤，想要成为他们本来不是的样子，并最终让它实现。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。
Our program today in three acts. Act One, Girls, Girls, Girls. The story of teenagers who were born as boys, but live as girls in Los Angeles.
我们今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，女孩，女孩，女孩。讲述了在洛杉矶，天生是男孩但以女孩身份生活的青少年们的故事。
Act Two, Agent to the Stars. A fan's unlikely dream to meet his favorite movie star accidentally works. Partly to his delight, partly to his horror.
第二幕，明星经纪人。一个粉丝想要见到他最喜欢的电影明星的不可思议的梦想，竟然意外地实现了。部分让他欣喜，部分让他恐惧。
Act Three, Airel Sharon, Shimon Peres, David Ben Gurion, and me! An American teenager who dreams someday of becoming the prime minister of a nation where he does not even reside. Stay with us.
第三幕，阿里尔·沙龙，希蒙·佩雷斯，大卫·本·古里安，还有我！一个梦想着有一天成为一个他甚至不住在那里的国家的总理的美国少年。请继续收听。
Act one, Girls, Girls, Girls.
第一幕，女孩，女孩，女孩。
Over the last 10 years in Los Angeles, there has been a noticeable increase in the number of transsexual teenagers. These are both boys and girls. You see them on the streets. Both are on the rise, but the boys who live as girls are a little more visible.
过去10年里，在洛杉矶，变性青少年的数量有了显著增长。他们既有男孩也有女孩。你在街上能看到他们。两者都在增加，但那些以女孩身份生活的男孩稍微明显一点。
As you might expect, they prefer to be called "she" not "he." And "girls" not "boys." Cris Beam has spent the last two years getting to know these kids, interviewing them, writing about them, and she tells this story.
正如你所料，他们更喜欢被称为“她”而不是“他”。被称为“女孩”而不是“男孩”。Cris Beam过去两年一直在了解这些孩子，采访他们，书写他们，她讲述了这个故事。
I'm writing a book about transsexual youth. In Los Angeles where I live, there are hundreds of them, noisily laughing on street corners. Runaways or castoffs from families who can't possibly understand.
我正在写一本关于变性青少年的书。在我居住的洛杉矶，有成百上千个这样的孩子，在街角喧闹地笑着。他们是离家出走者，或是被那些无法理解他们的家庭抛弃的孩子。
There have always been transsexuals in Los Angeles and everywhere else, but never so many kids, so visible and so determined. They come here because they hear they can find underground hormones, or friends. Or simply because this is the biggest city they can think of. And because they fall under the radar of regular social services, on the street they're playing doctor, beautician, health advisor and shrink to one another.
洛杉矶和其他任何地方一直都有变性人，但从来没有这么多孩子，这么显眼，这么坚定。他们来到这里是因为听说可以找到地下的荷尔蒙，或者朋友。或者仅仅因为这是他们能想到的最大的城市。而且因为他们处于常规社会服务机构的雷达之外，在街头上，他们互为医生、美容师、健康顾问和心理医生。
I posted fliers around asking them to share their stories. I got one call from a 20 year old woman who agreed to meet with me. Her name was Foxxjazell and she told me she was going to be the first international transsexual pop star. She described herself so I could recognize her. I'm very beautiful, she said. I'm tall and black with butter pecan caramel skin and long, luxurious, silky hair. She suggested we meet at the Red Lobster.
我到处张贴传单，请求他们分享自己的故事。我接到了一个20岁女性的电话，她同意和我见面。她的名字叫Foxxjazell，她告诉我她将成为第一个国际变性流行歌星。她描述了自己的样子以便我能认出她。我非常漂亮，她说。我身材高挑，是黑人，有着黄核桃仁焦糖色的皮肤和又长、又奢华、如丝绸般的头发。她建议我们在红龙虾餐厅见面。
When I got there, I saw she wasn't lying. She was really pretty. She wore glitter on her eyes and had silver charms braided into her hair. On her ripped jeans she had scrawled the words "Latins do it better."
当我到那里时，我发现她没有撒谎。她真的很漂亮。她的眼睛上涂着闪粉，头发里编着银色的装饰品。她那条破洞牛仔裤上潦草地写着“拉丁裔做得更好”。
She'd grown up Dwight Eric Jackson in Birmingham, Alabama. As early as she can remember, she felt like a girl. When the teacher would parcel kids off into boy and girl teams in kindergarten, Foxx stood there frozen, not knowing which group to join. And when she hit adolescence, Foxx had to invent herself like any other teenager, but without the templates-- prom queen, brainiac, jock.
她在阿拉巴马州伯明翰长大，原名Dwight Eric Jackson。从她记事起，她就觉得自己像个女孩。在幼儿园，当老师把孩子们分成男生组和女生组时，Foxx站在那里，不知所措，不知道该加入哪个组。当她进入青春期时，Foxx不得不像其他任何青少年一样创造自己，但却没有模板——舞会皇后、优等生、运动员。
Foxx had to make up a whole persona that fit with the gender inside her. It's a trait that attracts me to these transgender kids in general. Their intense drive to develop their own reality, and then their own rules to get there.
Foxx必须编造出一个完全符合她内心性别的角色。这种特质吸引我关注这些变性孩子。他们开发自己现实的强烈驱动力，以及为了实现这一点而制定的规则。
For instance, for a few years in high school, inspired by Prince, Foxx replaced her own name with a symbol.
例如，高中几年里，受Prince启发，Foxx用一个符号代替了自己的名字。
I did not use my name at all. I would use a pink triangle. I would always carry this pink marker around with me every day. And if I wanted to sign my name or did my homework or something like that, I'll put a pink triangle on there. Because the pink triangle was originally from the Holocaust. Because back then, a lot of the gay people there in the concentration camps got pink triangles put on them. But being the creative soul that I am, I put something a little bit different on there. I put a sign of a woman on there. And don't you know, it's like the same sign that you see like when you go into the women's bathroom it has that little symbol of a woman.
我根本不用自己的名字。我用一个粉色三角形。我每天总是随身带着这支粉色马克笔。如果我想签名，或者做家庭作业之类的，我就会在上面画一个粉色三角形。因为粉色三角形最初源于大屠杀。因为那时，集中营里很多同性恋者被标记上粉色三角形。但作为一个富有创造力的灵魂，我在上面加了一点不同的东西。我在上面加了一个女性的符号。你难道不知道吗，这就像你进女厕所时看到的那个女性小符号一样。
Like the woman in a skirt?
就像那个穿着裙子的女人？
Yes, exactly. It looked exactly like that. And that's the symbol I adapted. And I even got a necklace like that and people would ask me, what does that mean? What does that mean? Everyone would ask me that. And I would love when people would ask me that because I would love to just tell them. I would say this. I would say, it means that I'm a woman trapped inside of a male's body. That's what it means.
是的，完全正确。看起来一模一样。那就是我采纳的符号。我甚至买了一条那样的项链，人们会问我，那是什么意思？那是什么意思？每个人都会问我。我喜欢人们问我，因为我喜欢直接告诉他们。我会这么说。我会说，这意味着我是一个被困在男性身体里的女人。这就是它的意思。
Foxx cross-dressed in secret. And alone in her room, pretended to be Janet Jackson. Sometimes she'd sneak out her window late at night in cheap Halloween wigs and halter tops, and just walk around her neighborhood. She wouldn't run into anybody, she just liked how it felt.
Foxx私下里进行异装。在房间里独自一人时，她假装自己是Janet Jackson。有时她深夜会戴着廉价的万圣节假发，穿着挂脖上衣从窗户溜出去，在街区散步。她不会遇到任何人，她只是喜欢那种感觉。
Unlike the parents of many of these kids who will throw them out at first discovery of a stiletto in a school bag, Foxx's parents were supportive of their only child. They just worried for her safety. But she worried for her sanity. She knew she had to go someplace where the unusual was more usual. So as soon as she graduated, she got a job, saved her cash, and bought a bus ticket to Los Angeles. And this is where her story really begins.
不像很多在学校包里发现高跟鞋时就把孩子赶出家门的父母，Foxx的父母对他们唯一的孩子很支持。他们只是担心她的安全。但她担心自己的精神状态。她知道她必须去一个不寻常的事物更常见的地方。所以她一毕业，就找了工作，存了钱，买了一张去洛杉矶的巴士票。而这正是她故事真正开始的地方。
Cahuenga and Hollywood Boulevard is where I  first got off. And this is where I had said to myself, my name was going to be paved down there on one of these stars one of these days.
卡温加和好莱坞大道是我第一次下车的地方。我对自己说，总有一天，我的名字会被镶在那里的某一颗星上。
The corner of Cahuenga and Hollywood is part of the famous Hollywood Walk of Stars. Every square of sidewalk is embedded with a polished star and a name.
卡温加和好莱坞路口是著名的好莱坞星光大道的一部分。每一块人行道都镶嵌着一颗抛光的星星和一个名字。
Madge Bellamy, I don't know who that is. Harry von Zell, I mean, Alfred Green. If these people were so famous, why haven't I ever heard of them? Oh my God.
Madge Bellamy，我不知道那是谁。Harry von Zell，还有Alfred Green。如果这些人这么出名，为什么我从来没听说过他们？天哪。
Foxx was just 18 when she got to LA, but she arranged to stay in a group home called Covenant House, where a lot of stray gay kids go. In some ways, it's easier for trans kids to hook up with other girls like themselves than it has ever been. Foxx found where to stay in LA from the gay yellow pages before she ever left Birmingham. Some trans kids use the internet to figure this out.
Foxx到洛杉矶时才18岁，但她安排住在一家名为Covenant House的收容所，那里有很多流浪的同性恋孩子。在某些方面，变性孩子比以往任何时候都更容易联系到和自己一样的女孩。Foxx在离开伯明翰之前就通过同性恋黄页找到了在洛杉矶的住处。有些变性孩子利用互联网来搞清楚这些。
But the jump to full tilt womanhood came on a casual Friday at the telemarketing firm where Foxx was working at the time. On Fridays, employees were told they could wear whatever was comfortable. Most people showed up in jeans and loafers. Foxx showed up as a woman.
但向全职女性身份的转变发生在一个周五，当时Foxx在一家电话营销公司工作。在周五，员工被告知可以穿任何舒适的衣服。大多数人穿着牛仔裤和乐福鞋就来了。Foxx则以女性身份出现。
It finally just came down. And it was just like Foxxjazell. I mean all those years trapped inside of that boy's body. I mean, 19 years to be exact. She just couldn't take anymore. She just couldn't take just dressing up on nights, just dressing up on weekends. She wanted to be out all the time.
它最终还是发生了。就像Foxxjazell一样。我的意思是，被困在那个男孩身体里这么多年。准确地说是19年。她实在受不了了。她再也受不了仅仅在晚上打扮，仅仅在周末打扮。她想一直以女性身份示人。
Since that day last January, Foxx never dressed as a man again. She's fully Foxx, even when she goes home to Alabama for Christmas.
从去年一月的那天起，Foxx再也没有穿过男装。她完全是Foxx，即使她圣诞节回到阿拉巴马州老家时也是如此。
Then what happened? Did you decide to go on hormones pretty soon after that?
然后发生了什么？你决定在那之后很快就开始注射荷尔蒙吗？
It would be five months to be exact before I actually started hormones. I went to the LA free clinic. I went to Dr. Victory. I got a prescription for Premarin 2.5, the pills, the little purple pills. And I waited until my insurance kicked in in the middle of May at my job, and I went out and I bought my first bottle of hormones. I was just so happy. I really wanted to just swallow the whole bottle.
准确地说是五个月后我才真正开始服用荷尔蒙。我去了洛杉矶免费诊所。我去了Victory医生那里。我得到了一张倍美力（Premarin）2.5的处方，那种紫色的小药片。我等到五月中旬工作保险生效，就出去买了我的第一瓶荷尔蒙。我当时太开心了。我真想把整瓶都吞下去。
Taking hormones, which gives them breast, redistribute fat in a more feminine way, soften the face, are only one part of transitioning. There are all kinds of unwritten rules to keep the girls in check. And mainly, they center round appearance and passability. When someone recognizes you're genetically male, it's called getting "clocked" on the West Coast or "spooked" on the East. And no one ever wants that to happen.
服用荷尔蒙，它可以让她们长出乳房，以更女性化的方式重新分配脂肪，柔化面部，这只是转变的一部分。有各种各样的不成文规定来约束女孩们。主要是围绕外表和通关率。在西海岸，当别人认出你是基因上的男性时，这被称为“被抓包”（clocked），在东海岸被称为“惊吓”（spooked）。没有人希望发生这种事。
One girl I talked with described having some guy at a restaurant taunt, "Hey, dude" as she passed by. And it was so traumatizing it kept her from dressing for months afterwards. So the girls are always monitoring each other, keeping an eye out for bad makeup or fake looking boobs, and showering praise on anything fishy. Being fishy is the highest compliment you can get. It means you look like you were born that way. That you were born a girl.
我交谈过的一个女孩描述说，在餐馆里被某个男人嘲笑“嘿，哥们儿”，这让她非常受创，以至于之后几个月都不敢打扮。所以女孩们总是互相监督，留意糟糕的妆容或看起来很假的乳房，并对任何“像样”（fishy）的东西大加赞赏。“像样”是你能得到的最高赞美。这意味着你看起来就像天生如此。就像你天生就是个女孩。
It starts with the voice. If you really don't have a fishy voice that can really just destroy the whole image.
这始于声音。如果你真的没有一个像样的声音，那真的会毁了整个形象。
A lot of times you can have all the makeup in the world, but if you look like a brick, or you're just not passable, I mean--
很多时候，你可以有世界上所有的化妆品，但如果你看起来像块砖头，或者就是不合格，我的意思是——
What does it mean to look like a "brick?"
看起来像“砖头”是什么意思？
To look like a brick, that's a term that a lot of girls use as far as a man in a dress. It means that you may have on a dress and makeup, but yet it's so obvious that you're a guy.
看起来像砖头，这是很多女孩形容穿裙子的男人的术语。这意味着你可能穿着裙子化着妆，但很明显你是个男人。
Do they say that to each other? Do they call each other that?
她们会这样说对方吗？她们互相这样称呼吗？
Yeah. A lot of them will say it behind their face and stuff like that. "This dame looks like a brick! This dame, she's bricking it up!" But that's how a lot of girls say that.
会。很多会在背后这样说。“这娘们看起来像块砖头！这娘们，她又在装模作样了！”但这就是很多女孩表达的方式。
Do you think that girls are critical of each other? Because it seems to me when I see them on the street, there's a whole lot of criticism if one doesn't look the right way or one doesn't fit into a certain image.
你认为女孩们对彼此苛刻吗？因为在我看来，当我在街上看到她们时，如果一个人看起来不对劲或不符合某种形象，就会受到很多批评。
I'll say this about myself. I do feel insecure sometimes if I go out with another girl that isn't as passable as I am. Because for one thing, it's bad enough if you get clocked. But if you're with another girl that is not passable that's going to get you clocked even more, that brings your self-esteem down. So a lot of girls and even myself, won't even go out in public with less passable girls. Or girls that are going to bring ridicule to them.
我对自己这么说。如果我和另一个不如我通关率高的女孩一起出去，有时会感到不安。因为首先，被抓包已经够糟糕了。但如果你和另一个不合格的女孩在一起，会让你更容易被抓包，这会降低你的自尊心。所以很多女孩，甚至我自己，甚至不会和那些不合格的女孩一起出现在公共场合。或者那些会给她们招致嘲笑的女孩。
That seems pretty harsh.
这似乎太苛刻了。
It's harsh, but you have to realize. I mean, being a transgender woman is bad enough, so why would you want to put more gasoline on the fire?
很苛刻，但你必须意识到。我的意思是，做一个变性女性已经够糟糕了，所以为什么还要火上浇油呢？
There's a certain strip of Santa Monica Boulevard in Hollywood that Foxx says is famous worldwide. It's where straight, often married men, come to pick up young, transgender prostitutes. It's also where just out transgender kids often first spot their own kind and can imagine a place to blend in. They hang out at Benito's, an all-night taco stand.
好莱坞的圣莫尼卡大道有一段路，Foxx说那是世界闻名的。那是异性恋，通常已婚的男人来找年轻的变性妓女的地方。这也是刚入行的变性孩子经常第一次发现同类并想象一个可以融入的地方。他们经常在Benito's待着，这是一个全天候营业的塔可摊。
Kids will stand around gossip and laugh, go turn a trick, hang out some more, bop into nearby dance clubs on and off the boulevard.
孩子们会站在那里闲聊大笑，去接个客，再回来聚一聚，时不时进出大道附近的舞蹈俱乐部。
You look so good.
你看上去真棒。
It's been so long since I've seen you.
好久没见到你了。
When Foxx and I dropped in at Benito's this month, she ran into an old friend she hadn't seen in ages.
这个月当我和Foxx在Benito's停下时，她遇到了一个她很久没见的老朋友。
Where you living at now?
你现在住在哪儿？
Where am I living? I'm living with my man. I've got a husband that I've had for two years and we've got a house and got an apartment. And the months really slow, so we got to come up with half of this month's rent and still got to go come up with next month's rent on the first.
我住在哪儿？我和我的男人住在一起。我有了一个在一起两年的丈夫，我们有房子，还有公寓。但每个月手头都很紧，所以我们得凑够这个月的房租，而且还得在下个月一号凑出下个月的房租。
So you're out here getting your work on?
所以你出来这里干活了？
I don't work all the time, but just some time.
我不总是干这个，只是偶尔。
I know the feeling, girl. I mean, sometimes I have to work. I have to do it too.
我明白那种感觉，女孩。我的意思是，有时候我必须干活。我也必须这样做。
You smoke weed?
你抽大麻吗？
No.
不。
Oh, OK. I was going to say--
哦，好的。我本来想说——
It's been so long since I've seen you.
好久没见到你了。
Girls who have just derived in LA might show up here to socialize for a few weeks, and then turn a trick for some cash. It's by then that they've learned how hard it is to get a legitimate job when you're 17 and have both a male ID and C cup breasts. So sex work becomes the option.
刚到洛杉矶的女孩可能会来这里社交几周，然后为了钱接客。到那时她们才知道，当你17岁，既有男性身份证又有C罩杯乳房时，找到一份合法的工作有多难。所以性工作成了选择。
It can be dangerous, especially for the younger girls. Some of whom have been kicked out by their parents at 13 or 14, and are looking for a place to stay when they're talking to johns.
这可能很危险，尤其是对年轻女孩来说。她们中有些人在13或14岁时就被父母赶了出来，在和嫖客交谈时还在寻找住处。
Foxx used to work with the Boulevard, but now she's moved onto office jobs.
Foxx过去常在大道工作，但现在她转行做办公室工作了。
Whenever I do work the Boulevard, whenever I have to work the Boulevard, I have a purpose in mind. And that's to get money for that point in time, whether it's to booked studio time, or whatever. And most of the time I really try to stay away from the Boulevard. I haven't worked it in a long while. Especially since I've had a stable job. Basically, it's something that all of us girls have to do because for one thing, we're not sought after as like, the number one type of employee.
每当我在大道工作，每当我不得不去大道工作时，我都有一个目的。那就是为了那个时间段的钱，无论是为了付录音室的费用，还是其他什么。大多数时候我真的尽量远离大道。我已经很久没在那工作了。特别是在有了稳定工作之后。基本上，这是我们所有女孩都不得不做的事，因为首先，我们并不是那种最受追捧的员工类型。
What is it like trying to get a job as a young, transgender person?
作为一名年轻的变性人，找工作是什么感觉？
It can be very frustrating. Because I would say that the last couple of jobs I've been at-- last couple jobs, I've had a big problem with using the women's restroom. It's like, genetic women, they can be very supportive for transgender women as far as our whole transition, helping us out with our makeup, giving us tips on men. But it's like when it comes to the bathroom, that's like off limits. It's like, we've just intruded their personal space and I don't understand that. And the last two jobs I was at, a lot of women had a problem with we using the women's restroom. And I'm like, OK, I look like a woman. I'm build like a woman. I have breasts like a woman. And you want me to go use the men's restroom?
这可能非常令人沮丧。因为我想说，我过去两份工作——过去两份工作，我在使用女厕所方面遇到了很大的问题。就像，生理女性，她们在整个转变过程中可以非常支持变性女性，帮助我们化妆，给我们一些关于男人的建议。但当涉及到厕所时，那是禁区。就像，我们侵犯了她们的个人空间，我不明白这一点。我过去的两份工作中，很多女性对我们使用女厕所都有意见。而我觉得，好吧，我看起来像个女人。我的身材像个女人。我有像女人一样的乳房。而你想要我去用男厕所？
If anything, that's going to mess up a little kid. Just imagine some little boy going to the restroom and he sees this really nice-looking Jennifer Lopez look-alike woman standing up urinating at the urinal. That's going to just destroy his whole mind concept.
如果非要那样，那会毁了一个小孩子的。想象一下，某个小男孩走进厕所，看到这个看起来很像詹妮弗·洛佩兹的女人站在小便池前小便。那会彻底摧毁他的心智概念。
The girls on Santa Monica can make $200, $300 in a night, but will talk surprisingly casually about their job. For some, there's a bit of a thrill to tantalizing the straight men who would normally rebuff them. And for others, it's an unfortunate pause on the path to day work.
圣莫尼卡大道上的女孩们一晚上能赚200、300美元，但谈论她们的工作时却出奇地随意。对一些人来说，挑逗那些通常会拒绝她们的异性恋男人有一点刺激。而对另一些人来说，这是通往日常工作道路上的一次不幸停顿。
So many girls come to Santa Monica Boulevard and they have that Pretty Woman concept that oh, I'm going to go out here and work the Boulevard. I'm going to meet a Richard Gere look-alike and he's going to be a millionaire. And he's going to marry me and we're going to have children. I think that's what a lot of girls really think. They have that Pretty Woman concept.
很多女孩来到圣莫尼卡大道时，都有那种《风月俏佳人》的观念，噢，我要到这里来在这条大道上工作。我会遇到一个长得像理查·基尔的人，他会是个百万富翁。他会娶我，我们会生孩子。我想很多女孩真的这么想。她们有那种《风月俏佳人》的观念。
Do you have that fantasy?
你有那种幻想吗？
I tend to have that fantasy from time to time. And I've actually met a couple of men on the Boulevard that have a little money and they want to spend on me.
我不时会有那种幻想。而且我实际上在大道上遇到过几个有点钱的男人，他们想为我花钱。
Everyone, come on. Everybody in the arena come on and watch me do my thing. Watch me do my thing. I like to do my thing.
大家，来吧。竞技场里的每一个人，来看着我做我的事。看着我做我的事。我喜欢做我的事。
It's Friday night at Foxx's tiny studio apartment. And while Foxx sings and raps with her friend [UNINTELLIGIBLE], two of her drag daughters, 15 year old Angela and 18 year old Ariel, are getting ready to go dancing at an underage club.
这是Foxx那间狭小的单身公寓里的周五晚上。当Foxx和她的朋友们一起唱歌说唱时，她的两个变装女儿，15岁的Angela和18岁的Ariel，正准备去一个未成年人俱乐部跳舞。
Luckily, both kids are petite and the onset of puberty has been slow. Their faces are soft and in their clingy nylon dresses, bobbed wigs and knee high boots, they pass amazingly well.
幸运的是，两个孩子都很娇小，而且青春期开始得较慢。她们的面孔柔和，穿着紧身的尼龙裙、波波头假发和及膝靴，她们的女性形象看起来非常真实。
They dress like any Latina high schooler in LA would-- baby doll cute-- but a little more trampy than a mom would like.
她们的穿着就像洛杉矶任何一个拉丁裔高中生一样——可爱的小洋娃娃装——但比妈妈们喜欢的稍微风骚一点。
Do I look pretty? Do I look pretty?
我看起来漂亮吗？我看起来漂亮吗？
Does she look pretty? Yes you do.
她看起来漂亮吗？是的，你很漂亮。
Angela and Ariel, like a handful of other local kids, keep their wigs, heels, handbags, and makeup at Foxx's. Angela and Ariel both still go to high school and live at boys during the day, and don't want to risk getting caught by their families. While some of the other teens who live on the streets just don't want to get their stuff stolen. So Foxx's place is a sort of de facto dressing room come clubhouse, where kids come in and out to dress up, eat Foxx's food, get some motherly advice, and often crash on her couch.
Angela和Ariel，像其他一些当地孩子一样，把她们的假发、高跟鞋、手提包和化妆品存放在Foxx那里。Angela和Ariel白天都还在上高中，以男孩的身份生活，不想冒被家人发现的风险。而一些流浪在街头的青少年则只是不想让自己的东西被偷。所以Foxx的住处是一个事实上的更衣室兼俱乐部，孩子们进进出出进行打扮，吃Foxx的食物，得到一些像母亲一样的建议，并经常在她的沙发上过夜。
I was there for hours watching them do and re-do their makeup, primp and fluff and gaze into the mirror. And pull an astonishing number of gogo boots out of Foxx's closet.
我在那里呆了几个小时，看着她们化妆、卸妆、打扮、整理，对着镜子凝视。并从Foxx的衣柜里拿出数量惊人的Go-go靴。
You don't have a bra on? You can put the water balloons, so they can look big and soft. At the same time when you walk, they'll move.
你没穿内衣吗？你可以放水球进去，这样它们看起来又大又软。同时当你走动时，它们会动。
They fill their bras with water balloons. Hormones would get them breast in a matter of months and would add weight to their narrow hips and backsides. But for now, neither has started taking.
她们在胸罩里塞进水球。荷尔蒙会在几个月内让她们长出乳房，并增加窄臀和后背的重量。但目前，两人都还没有开始服用。
There's a thriving black market for hormones here in LA. And, like many prescription drugs that are purchased over the counter in Mexico, estrogen is smuggled across the border and is sold in the swap meets with other Mexican pharmaceuticals. In the rush to fill out and pass, girls will shoot massive amounts of hormones into their butts every week. Often causing PMS-like mood swings. Sometimes they'll also inject silicone and oils directly into their hips, butts, knees, and even cheeks, all to round out the harder edges.
洛杉矶有一个繁荣的荷尔蒙黑市。而且，就像许多在墨西哥柜台售卖的处方药一样，雌激素被偷运过边境，与其他墨西哥药物一起在跳蚤市场出售。为了尽快发育和通过性别检验，女孩们每周会往屁股里注射大量的荷尔蒙。这经常导致类似经前综合症（PMS）的情绪波动。有时她们还会直接把硅胶和油注射进臀部、屁股、膝盖甚至脸颊，所有这些都是为了填补较硬的线条。
There are a few doctors who will prescribe hormones to kids, but the waiting lists are long. And some feel the doses are too conservative. Foxx is going the legal route with an estrogen prescription and her doctor tells her to expect breasts about the size of her mother's. After all, you can't override genetics.
有少数医生会给孩子开荷尔蒙处方，但等待名单很长。而且有些人觉得剂量太保守了。Foxx选择了合法的路线，持有雌激素处方，她的医生告诉她，乳房大小预计会和她妈妈的一样。毕竟，你无法凌驾于基因之上。
This particular Friday is special, as the girls are celebrating Ariel's retirement party. Ariel is 18, small, Latina, and even when she wears her baggy boy clothes, looks like a shy little girl who curls herself into her chair when she talks. She tell me she's decided to retire. To stop dressing and live as a boy for one whole month to see if she can make it. Tonight is her last night in drag.
这个周五很特别，因为女孩们正在庆祝Ariel的退休派对。Ariel 18岁，娇小，拉丁裔，即使穿着宽松的男装，看起来也像个害羞的小女孩，说话时把自己蜷缩在椅子里。她告诉我她决定退休了。停止打扮，以男孩身份生活整整一个月，看看她能不能做到。今晚是她最后一次异装。
Put powder on your face, your ears. Behind your ears and your neck. And your chest.
在你的脸上抹粉，还有耳朵。耳朵后面和脖子。还有你的胸部。
Ariel named herself after the Little Mermaid in the Disney movie. For so many transgender kids Ariel's age, The Little Mermaid is hugely significant. After all, the film came out when they were 9 or 10 and give them hope. The cartoon Ariel is a mermaid who hates the body she was born with and wants nothing more than to be a real girl.
Ariel给自己取名源于迪斯尼电影《小美人鱼》。对于像Ariel这个年纪的许多变性孩子来说，小美人鱼意义重大。毕竟，这部电影上映时她们才9或10岁，给了她们希望。卡通形象的Ariel是一条讨厌自己出生身体的美人鱼，最渴望的就是成为一个真正的女孩。
She was sitting in the ocean. She wanted to be a human being. And at the end, she turned into a girl and she just looked like a girl. And she never got clocked. And then she went for what she wanted and she did what she wanted. At the end she was happy. Everyone's happy. Her story is just-- I don't know. It'll be like my mom telling me I can be a girl and you can do this. Like that.
她坐在海洋里。她想成为一个人。最后，她变成了一个女孩，看起来就像个女孩。而且她从来没被抓包。她追求她想要的，做了她想做的。最后她很幸福。每个人都很幸福。她的故事就是——我不知道。就像我妈妈告诉我我可以成为一个女孩，你可以做到这一点。就像那样。
Do you think your mom ever would say it's OK to be a girl?
你觉得你妈妈会说成为女孩没问题吗？
No.
不会。
Foxx thinks there's no way Ariel's retirement is going to last. She remembers her own teenage-hood and how she would vow to give up dressing as a woman, but she could never help coming back.
Foxx认为Ariel的退休计划根本持续不了。她记得自己的青少年时期，她是多么发誓要放弃打扮成女人，但她总是忍不住回来。
Today was-- I don't know if it was the rain. But it was just a depressing day for me.
今天——我不知道是不是因为下雨。但对我来说，这是令人沮丧的一天。
A few days after the retirement party, I met up with Foxx again at her apartment. We drank her Kool-Aid from plastic cups and sat on her secondhand couch with the shades drawn.
退休派对后几天，我又在Foxx的公寓见到了她。我们用塑料杯喝着她做的酷爱饮料，拉着窗帘坐在她的二手沙发上。
Everything just seemed to be coming together now. But I still have this sense of emptiness inside because apparently Valentine's Day is coming up. Plus my birthday's going to be right after that. And it doesn't make any things much better that I haven't had my first relationship yet.
一切似乎都走上了正轨。但我内心仍然有一种空虚感，因为情人节显然快到了。再加上我的生日就在那之后。而且我还没有开始我的第一次恋情，这并没有让事情变得更好。
Whenever I see Foxx she talks obsessively about finding a boyfriend. She's visited psychics and grilled all her friends for leads and can't figure out why nothing has panned out. As she's gotten older, transitioning into a woman is no longer the central drama of her life. Getting a boyfriend is.
每当我见到Foxx，她总是痴迷地谈论寻找男朋友。她拜访过灵媒，盘问过所有的朋友寻找线索，无法理解为什么什么都没有进展。随着年龄增长，转变为女性不再是她生活的核心戏剧。找个男朋友才是。
Today's story is typical. She tells me about a guy down the street who introduced himself as Christopher Columbus. He told her she looked good and they exchanged phone numbers, but he never ended up calling her.
今天的故事很典型。她告诉我街上有一个男人，他自我介绍叫哥伦布。他告诉她她看起来不错，他们交换了电话号码，但他最终没给她打过电话。
It was probably, at least a month after that, he still didn't call. And I was walking on that same block and he was out with a bunch of his friends. And one of his friends I think wanted to talk to me. He said, hey, what's up? And the guy that identified himself as Christopher Columbus, he came out of nowhere and said, that's a man. That's a man. You're a guy. You're a guy and you're ugly. You're ugly. And I just walked away. And my heart was just so broken. And like now, every time I pass by his house and everything he's standing outside with his friends or something. He still teases me and say things like that.
大概在那之后至少一个月，他还是没打。我走在同一条街上，他正和一群朋友在一起。他的一位朋友我想大概是想和我说话。他说，嘿，你好吗？那个自称哥伦布的男人突然冲出来说，那是个男人。那是个人妖。你是个男人。你是个男人，你真丑。你真丑。我就走开了。我的心碎了。现在，每次我经过他家，或者他站在外面和朋友们在一起时。他还会嘲笑我，说那种话。
The last time he talked to me was probably like three weeks ago. And he asked me, let me ask you something. Have you had it cut it off yet? And he was referring to have I had the surgery yet. And I said, that's personal. And he said, well, I guess that means that you haven't had it cut off. And I just walked away.
他上次跟我说话大概是三周前。他问我，让我问你点事。你把那东西切掉了吗？他指的是我有没有做过手术。我说，那是私事。他说，好吧，我想那意味着你还没切掉。我就走开了。
How do you handle that kind of sadness and that kind of rejection?
你如何处理那种悲伤和那种拒绝？
Well, it's been the inspiration for five songs that I've written.
好吧，这成为了我写的五首歌的灵感来源。
Foxx wants to be a huge star. She's a singer and a rapper and she spends all of her money on studio time, recording songs about coming out, and being transgender, and wanting the world to understand.
Foxx想成为大明星。她是一名歌手兼说唱歌手，她把所有的钱都花在录音室时间上，录制关于出柜、成为变性人、想要世界理解的歌曲。
She imagines being somewhat of a sex symbol too, and knows her future boyfriend will have to put up with that. She constantly worries about when that boyfriend will come.
她也想象自己成为某种性感偶像，并知道未来的男朋友必须忍受这一点。她不断地担心那个男朋友什么时候会来。
It was a few weeks after her 21st birthday that Foxx called me up all excited. It had finally happened, she gushed. Everything she dreamed of. She told me she had met a man. Actually, they met a week ago and he was now living in her apartment.
在Foxx 21岁生日几周后，她兴奋地给我打电话。终于发生了，她滔滔不绝地说。她梦想的一切。她告诉我她遇到了一个男人。实际上，他们一周前认识的，现在他已经搬进她的公寓了。
It's really exciting because I mean, it's like last week I'm single and now this week I have a boyfriend and he's cooking for me. And I'm falling in love with him and he's falling in love with me. It's just happening so fast. It's like a dream.
这真的很令人兴奋，因为我的意思是，上周我还是单身，现在这周我就有了男朋友，他还在为我做饭。我爱上了他，他也爱上了我。一切发生得太快了。就像做梦一样。
If there's any question in your mind at all about straight guys going for transgender girls, remember, these girls are fantastically adorable. Foxx's new boyfriend, Sergio, is 23. He's a Puerto Rican guy from New York with an ex-wife and a daughter. Foxx is the first transgender woman he's ever dated. He's straight and sweet and totally in love.
如果你的脑海中对异性恋男人追求变性女孩有任何疑问，记住，这些女孩非常可爱。Foxx的新男友Sergio 23岁。他是个来自纽约的波多黎各人，有个前妻和一个女儿。Foxx是他交往过的第一个变性女性。他是异性恋，很贴心，完全陷入了爱河。
I even tell them it's like, I don't believe you some time because of the fact that you're so fine and you can get any real girl that you want to. But yet, you're here with me. And I just want to pinch myself and just wake up.
我甚至告诉他们，我有的时候不相信你，因为你这么出色，你可以得到任何你想要的真正的女孩。但你却在这里和我在一起。我真想捏自己一把，然后醒过来。
How do you feel when she says that you could get any real girl? What does that do for you?
当她说你可以得到任何真正的女孩时，你感觉如何？这对你有什么影响？
Well, I actually said that maybe she's true about that, but my feeling is I can never find someone like her. And I think I'm going to be all right after this.
嗯，我实际上说也许她说得对，但我感觉我永远找不到像她这样的人了。而且我想在这之后我会没事的。
I wanted to comment about something. Sergio was listening to my song, "If I was a Real Girl" and he made a comment that just struck me. And I forgot what he said. What did you say, baby? When you listened to my song.
我想评论一下某件事。Sergio当时正在听我的歌《如果我是个真正的女孩》，他发表了一句让我印象深刻的评论。我忘了他说什么了。你说什么了，宝贝？当你听我的歌时。
Oh, I say, you don't have to be a real woman to somebody like me who cares and love you. I don't see what she has outside, I see what is inside of her. That's the point. That's the view that I see about all this thing. Like I always say, the heart doesn't see, only feels.
哦，我说，对于像我这样关心和爱你的人来说，你不需要成为一个真正的女人。我不在乎她外面有什么，我在乎她内在有什么。这就是重点。这就是我对这一切的看法。就像我常说的，心不看，只感受。
When I tell people about this book project they all want to know which of the kids are really women or really men. By which they mean, who has had the genital surgery. But the surgery is irrelevant. Lots of trans men never have it because it costs $70,000. And plenty of trans women, like Foxx, don't want it.
当我告诉人们这个书稿项目时，他们都想知道哪些孩子是真正的女性或真正的男性。他们的意思是，谁做了生殖器手术。但手术是不相关的。很多变性男性从来没做过，因为它要花7万美元。而且很多变性女性，像Foxx，也不想要。
It's funny, feminism has worked so hard to prove that women are more than what's in their pants. But when it comes to transsexuals, it's all people can think about. So I counter crudeness with crudeness and ask them, if you somehow got into an accident and lost everything below the waist, would you be any less woman, any less man? If you think you're a woman you are one. We're not used to that idea. We're not used to believing that gender is determined only by our hearts.
很有趣，女权主义为了证明女性不仅仅是裤子里的东西而努力工作。但当谈到变性人时，这就是人们唯一能想到的东西。所以我以粗俗对付粗俗，问他们，如果你不知怎么出了事故，腰部以下什么都没了，你还会少一点女人味，少一点男人味吗？如果你认为自己是女人，你就是。我们不习惯那种想法。我们不习惯相信性别仅仅由我们的内心决定。
In Ariel's case, she couldn't suppress this heart and her retirement turned out to be more of a pause then a real break.
在Ariel的例子中，她无法压抑这颗心，她的退休与其说是一个真正的结束，不如说更像是一个暂停。
So the last time that I saw you, you were deciding to retire and stop dressing. And how long were you going to take your retirement for?
上次我见到你时，你决定退休并停止打扮。你打算把退休计划持续多久？
For a month.
一个月。
And how long did it last?
结果持续了多久？
It lasted for like a week.
大概持续了一周。
A few days after her retirement party, Ariel's friends started calling her, asking her to go out, and dress up, and take pictures with them. So she went and it felt great. Though it scares her that if felt great.
退休派对后几天，Ariel的朋友们开始给她打电话，约她出去，一起打扮，一起拍照。所以她去了，感觉棒极了。尽管这让她害怕，因为感觉真的棒极了。
I failed. I did fail. It's like I'm going to go to hell. That's what I think in my head.
我失败了。我确实失败了。就像我要下地狱一样。我在脑子里就是这么想的。
Why would God disapprove?
上帝为什么要反对？
Because it's in the Bible that you were born a man and a man you are.
因为圣经里说你天生是个男人，你就是一个男人。
Did you learn anything from your retirement? Did you learn how to golf? Did you learn anything from your retirement?
你从退休中学会了什么吗？你学会打高尔夫了吗？你从退休中学到了什么吗？
Yes, that I'm a boy. I'm a woman.
是的，我是个男孩。我是个女人。
Ariel is struggling back and forth, dressing some days as a boy and some days as a girl. But guiltily. Ariel as a boy is withdrawn, blinking vacantly and drowning in baggy, hide-everything jeans. He almost disappears. But as a girl, Ariel is vibrant, believable, sassy. Claiming space with her walk and challenging you to meet her eye.
Ariel在来回挣扎，有时候打扮成男孩，有时候打扮成女孩。但心怀愧疚。作为男孩的Ariel很退缩，眼神空洞，淹没在宽松的、遮住一切的牛仔裤里。他几乎消失了。但作为女孩，Ariel充满活力、真实、时髦。她用走路的姿态占据空间，并挑战你与她对视。
When Ariel was going to a rough inner city school a few years back she tried to be tough and masculine. But the boy's still harassed her for acting too girlie and she had to drop out. To get even, she showed up one last time dressed up, as she says, hoochie, in a tiny dress and heels.
几年前，当Ariel在一所粗暴的内城学校上学时，她试图表现得强硬和阳刚。但男孩们仍然因为她表现得太娘而骚扰她，她不得不退学。为了报复，她最后一次打扮得，正如她所说的，风骚，穿着小裙子和高跟鞋出现了。
The boys didn't recognize her as she walked around the quad. And some even asked for her number. I love this defiance, this revenge in the face of such pain.
她在校园里走动时，男孩们没认出她。有些人甚至问她要电话号码。我喜欢这种反抗，在面对如此痛苦时的这种复仇。
Ariel recently had to leave her sister's house and south central neighborhood because neighbor boys, once again, we're threatening to kill her for acting too gay. She's now living across town in her own apartment with an older transgender woman. Ariel's still not dressing full time, but the other day she did call me up to see if I would take her out for her 19th birthday. She wanted me to buy her a wig.
Ariel最近不得不离开她姐姐的房子和南中央区的社区，因为邻居男孩们又一次威胁说要杀了她，因为她表现得太像同性恋。她现在住在大街另一头，和一位年长的变性女性一起住在自己的公寓里。Ariel仍然不是全职打扮，但前几天她确实打电话给我，看我是否愿意带她出去过19岁生日。她想让我给她买顶假发。
Cris Beam is a writer living in Los Angeles. These days, Foxxjazell has a day job doing street outreach to transgender youth. To hear her music you can download MP3 files from the This American Life website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
Cris Beam是住在洛杉矶的一名作家。如今，Foxxjazell有一份白天的工作，从事针对变性青少年的街头外展工作。要听她的音乐，你可以从《美国生活》网站下载MP3文件，www.thisamericanlife.org。
Coming up, somebody famous you've never heard of. Somebody who wanted a job you probably don't want. And the well-known catchphrase, "this is my boomstick." You know, this is my boomstick. In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个你从未听说过的名人。一个想要一份你可能不想要的工作的人。还有那句著名的口头禅，“这是我的雷管枪”。你知道，这是我的雷管枪。国际公共广播电台的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Living the Dream. People who decided to remake their lives around some new vision of themselves. We have arrived at act two of our program.
这是《美国生活》，我是Ira Glass。当然，我们每周在节目中选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目，生活梦想。那些决定围绕自己对生活的新愿景来重塑人生的人。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act two, Agent to the Stars. John Hodgman tells this story of a dream that was a modest dream. Modest enough that it could actually come true.
第二幕，明星经纪人。John Hodgman讲述了这个关于一个适度梦想的故事。适度到它真的能实现。
If there's one thing you learn the day you start working in publishing, it's that everyone wants to write a book. No matter how lowly your position, the moment you get that first job you can be sure that 18 of your father's friends will soon be calling you about how to get their spy novel published.
如果你在出版业开始工作的第一天学到了一件事，那就是每个人都想写书。无论你的职位多么卑微，当你得到第一份工作的那一刻，你可以肯定，父亲的18个朋友很快会打电话给你，询问如何出版他们的谍战小说。
There's something so alluring about becoming an author, and it's something so daunting and enigmatic about the process of getting published that even the most accomplished men and women, world travelers, captains of industry, cower before it. This is how the greenest publishing recruits end up editing the inner musings of gangsters, telling millionaires to kill their darlings, spell checking presidents. And this is how, with little training, less experience, and only a vague idea of what I was doing, I became the professional literary agent for the world famous movie star Mr. Bruce Campbell.
成为一名作家有着某种诱人的东西，而出版的过程又如此令人望而生畏且神秘，以至于即使是成就最卓著的男女，世界旅行者，工业巨头，也会在它面前退缩。这就是为什么最新鲜的出版新兵最终编辑黑帮的内心独白，告诉百万富翁要割舍他们的至爱，校对总统的拼写。这也是为什么，在几乎没有培训、经验更少，只有模糊想法的情况下，我成为了世界著名电影明星Bruce Campbell先生的职业文学代理人。
You don't know who Bruce Campbell is. That's fine. As his agent, I've had to explain it a lot. Bruce Campbell is an actor. He was Ellen's boss on Ellen , Jack on Jack of All Trades , Autolycus, King of Thieves on Xena: Warrior Princess . In the movies Maniac Cop 1 and Maniac Cop 2 he played the cop who was not a maniac. He's the sort of actor who dies in the first 10 minutes of the movie Congo . Which he did.
你不知道Bruce Campbell是谁。没关系。作为他的代理人，我不得不解释很多次。Bruce Campbell是一个演员。他曾是《艾伦》中艾伦的老板，《杰克全才》中的杰克，《齐娜：战士公主》中的“盗贼之王”Autolycus。在电影《鬼警探1》和《鬼警探2》中，他扮演了那个不是疯子的警察。他是那种在电影《刚果惊魂》前10分钟就死掉的演员。他确实死在那里。
The music you're listening to right now is the theme from The Adventures of Briscoe County Jr. in which Bruce Campbell played a cowboy. It was canceled after one season. We still use the theme song though, from time to time, to introduce sporting events, like the World Series or the Olympics.
你现在听到的音乐是《布里斯科县大冒险》的主题曲，Bruce Campbell在其中饰演一名牛仔。它只播了一季就被取消了。不过，我们还是会不时使用这首主题曲来介绍体育赛事，比如世界大赛或奥运会。
If none of this rings a bell, perhaps you've seen a movie called The Evil Dead or one of its two sequels. In Evil Dead II: Dead by Dawn there's a character named Ash, whose hand is infested by an evil spirit. After the possessed hand slaps him all over the house, he cuts it off with a chainsaw. But it still isn't dead. Ash goes out to the work shed and what follows is one of the great parodies ever to be filmed of the classic hero gets ready to kick-ass montage.
如果这些都没让你有印象，也许你见过一部叫《鬼玩人》的电影或者它的两部续集。《鬼玩人2：死亡之舞》里有一个叫Ash的角色，他的手被邪灵感染了。在那只被附身的手把他整屋子扇耳光之后，他用电锯把它切断了。但它还是没死。Ash走到工具棚，接着发生的是电影史上最伟大的模仿动作之一——英雄准备大干一场的蒙太奇。
Close up of Ash gathering his tools and ammunition, modifying the chain saw. Which he then straps on to the stump where his hand used to be. Pulling the rip chord, he uses it to saw the end of a double barreled shotgun. He twirls the gun cowboy style around his trigger finger, slips it into a holster on his back. As the chainsaw's engine roars, he stares into the camera and deadpans the immortal line--
特写镜头展示Ash收集工具和弹药，改造电锯。然后他把它绑在曾经是手的地方。拉动启动绳，他用它锯断了一把双管猎枪的枪管。他像牛仔一样用食指转动枪支，把它插进背后的皮套里。当电锯引擎咆哮时，他盯着镜头，死板地说了那句不朽的台词——
Groovy.
Groovy（酷毙了）。
That's Bruce Campbell. And with that line, a B-movie star was born. Because if you don't know who Bruce Campbell is there's a growing circle of devoted fans who do, and they want you to meet him. They build websites in his honor. They make refrigerator magnets with his picture on them and they sell them on e-Bay. When Napster was on its last legs this past spring, the only thing you could be sure to find there were German drinking songs and Bruce Campbell's most famous lines. "Groovy." "This is my boomstick." "Hail to the King, baby."
那就是Bruce Campbell。那句台词诞生了一位B级片明星。因为如果你不知道Bruce Campbell是谁，有一个不断扩大的忠实粉丝圈知道，他们想让你见到他。他们为他建立网站。他们制作印有他照片的冰箱贴，并在eBay上出售。当Napster在去年春天行将就木时，你唯一能确定找到的就是德国饮酒歌和Bruce Campbell最著名的台词。“Groovy。”“这是我的雷管枪。”“向国王致敬，宝贝。”
Hail to the King, baby. Good. Bad. I'm the guy with the gun. Give me some sugar, baby. I got news for you, pal. You ain't leading but two things right now, Jack and [BLEEP]. And Jack left town.
向国王致敬，宝贝。好的。坏的。我就是那个拿着枪的家伙。给我点糖果，宝贝。我有新闻告诉你，伙计。你现在除了两样东西什么也领导不了，杰克和[哔]。而杰克离开了镇子。
On their own or dropped over homemade techno music, they're the passwords into the inner circle of the cult of Bruce Campbell.
无论是自制还是混音在自制的高科技音乐里，它们都是进入Bruce Campbell邪教崇拜核心圈的密码。
The cult is nearly equally men and women, perhaps because Bruce's charm fall somewhere between Cary Grant and the Three Stooges. And maybe it's because he's not very well known that you end up feeling that he's your own personal celebrity that no one else knows about. Even if you're aware that Bruce Campbell has a small army of avid fans, there's something about him that makes you think that if you ever had the chance to meet him, the two of you would definitely hang out. You might even watch Bruce Campbell movies together.
这个粉丝圈男女比例几乎均等，也许是因为Bruce的魅力介于Cary Grant和“三个臭皮匠”之间。也许正是因为他不太出名，你最终会觉得他是你自己专属的、没人知道的明星。即使你知道Bruce Campbell有一小支狂热粉丝军团，他身上有什么东西让你觉得如果你有机会见到他，你们绝对会混在一起。你们甚至可能会一起看Bruce Campbell的电影。
That was my line of thinking anyway, in early 1997. I was a young, literary agent who had never sold a book, and a Bruce Campbell fan. That spring, my office finally was hooked up to something I had only heard whispers of called the World Wide Web. It didn't do much for office productivity, but on that first day I typed in the words Bruce and Campbell and it changed my life forever.
无论如何，那是我在1997年初的想法。我是一名年轻的文学代理人，从没卖过一本书，也是Bruce Campbell的粉丝。那年春天，我的办公室终于连接上了我只听说过传闻的东西，叫万维网。它对办公室生产力没多大帮助，但在第一天，我输入了Bruce和Campbell这两个词，它永远改变了我的生活。
It turned out that Bruce Campbell had his own website. And by his own, I mean his own. Not some slick corporate product, but a homemade looking affair maintained by volunteers, and featuring long essays from Bruce, advice to aspiring actors, notes on how much orange juice costs at the Cannes Film Festival. Reports from the set of McHale's Navy , a terrible Tom Arnold movie that no human would ever see.
事实证明Bruce Campbell有自己的网站。我说的“自己的”，是指他自己的。不是什么精美的企业产品，而是志愿者维护的自制网页，以Bruce的长篇散文、给想当演员的人的建议、关于戛纳电影节橙汁价格的笔记为特色。甚至还有《麦克海尔的海军》的片场报告，那是一部没有人会看的糟糕的Tom Arnold电影。
There was a link to an email address and I clicked on it and I stared at the empty form. I didn't know what to say. But then, of course, I did.
有一个电子邮件地址的链接，我点击了它，盯着那个空白表格。我不知道说什么。但当然，我还是写了。
I'm not only a fan, I wrote. I am also a professional literary agent. Have you ever thought about writing a book?
我不仅是粉丝，我写道。我还是一名职业文学代理人。你有没有想过写本书？
I didn't really expect him to write back. It certainly never occurred to me that this book nonsense would be something I'd ever have to think about again in my life. But after all, one man's B-movie god is another man's lonely working stiff factor stuck in New Zealand filming Xena: Warrior Princess , taking digital pictures of the strange southern hemisphere electrical outlets and posting them on the internet. He must've been bored out of his mind.
我没真的指望他回信。我当然也没想到这种写书的废话会是我一生中需要再次考虑的事情。但毕竟，一个人的B级片之神是另一个人的孤独打工仔，被困在新西兰拍摄《齐娜：战士公主》，拍着奇怪的南半球电源插座的数码照片并发布到网上。他一定无聊透顶了。
So the next thing I know I'm chatting with my hero on a crackly overseas connection about why the world must hear the confessions of a B-movie actor.
接下来的事情我知道了，我在裂纹不断的海外连线中和我的英雄聊天，谈论为什么世界必须听到B级片演员的自白。
People have celebrity dreams all the time. David Letterman moves into your apartment building. The Pope calls wanting to know if you need him to cat sit. But this phone call was the real thing.
人们总是有名人梦。大卫·莱特曼搬进你的公寓楼。教皇打电话来问你需不需要他帮你照顾猫。但这个电话是真实的。
There I was telling him how a book proposal is written, what an editor does, and on the other end of the line it's Bruce Campbell saying, "Uh huh, I see. A proposal you say." When he actually said groovy, it was very unsettling.
我当时告诉他书稿建议书是怎么写的，编辑是做什么的，而在电话那头，Bruce Campbell在说，“嗯哼，我明白。你说建议书？”当他真的说出“groovy”时，真是让人心神不宁。
I wanted to draw our conversation out in part because I thought I would probably never speak to him again, but I also wanted it to end as quickly as possible so I could put it behind me, make it into a story, get back to my normal life. To do this I even tried to discourage him. You should probably know I said, I've never sold a book before. But when we hung up, it wasn't over. I wouldn't go back to my normal life for a long time. Somehow, I don't remember how, I had sold him on me.
我想延长我们的谈话，部分是因为我觉得我可能再也不会跟他说话了，但也因为我想让它尽快结束，这样我就可以把它抛在脑后，把它变成一个故事，回到我正常的生活中。为此我甚至试图劝阻他。你应该知道，我说，我以前从未卖过书。但当我们挂断电话时，并没有结束。在很长一段时间里，我不会回到正常的生活中。不知怎么地，我不记得是怎么做到的，我让他认可了我。
After that, it was all downhill. And for a reason that I was too much of a fan to anticipate. The nature of B-movie stardom is such that you can be a celebrity on one hand and a nobody on the other. In a hotel that's hosting a horror movie expo, Bruce Campbell may not be able to get arrested in the lobby, but in the conventional halls he's a living god.
在那之后，一切都走下坡路了。原因是我太粉丝了，没能预料到。B级片明星的本质在于，你一方面可以是名人，另一方面可以是无名小卒。在举办恐怖片博览会的酒店里，Bruce Campbell在大堂里可能连被逮捕的机会都没有，但在会议大厅里，他是活着的上帝。
Turns out though, that most of the editors I sent his proposal to don't live in the conventional hall, they live in the lobby. If they were aware at all of the world in which Bruce is a star, it was only to take the time to sneer. Even those who were closet Bruce fans like me, were either unable or unwilling to take a stand and let their geek flags fly.
然而事实证明，我寄出他建议书的大多数编辑并不住在会议大厅，他们住在酒店大堂。如果他们对Bruce是明星的世界有一点了解，那也只是为了嘲笑一下。即使是像我一样躲在柜子里的Bruce粉丝，要么没有能力，要么不愿意站出来，展现他们的极客风采。
So this project, which initially seemed to spell easy money for both of us, gradually became a painful exercise in enduring rejection. Which put me in a complicated position. I had achieved my dream the moment Bruce first called me. The rest was gravy. But now, against all common sense, Bruce was entrusting me with his dream and I was letting him down.
所以这个项目，起初似乎对我们双方来说都是轻松挣钱的项目，逐渐变成了忍受拒绝的痛苦练习。这让我处于一个复杂的境地。在Bruce第一次给我打电话的那一刻，我就实现了梦想。剩下的都是额外收获。但现在，违背一切常识，Bruce把他的梦想托付给了我，而我却让他失望了。
It was time to bring out the big guns. Or, as we say in publishing, it was time to bring the pope over to cat sit. Bruce had to put himself in front of those few remaining editors who hadn't passed. Make them feel as giddy as I had during that first phone call. He had to come to New York.
是时候拿出杀手锏了。或者，正如我们在出版界所说的，是时候让教皇来照顾猫了。Bruce必须亲自面对那些还没拒绝的少数编辑。让他们感到我第一次通话时那样的眩晕。他必须来纽约。
I had obviously always wanted to meet Bruce in person, but not like this. Not when the sole reason for his coming was because I had to date, been failing miserably. So I tried to distract him with a quick tour of my office. We reached my cubicle at the top of the stairs. That's me, I said, with a quick wave to my sad, little chair. Let's go to dinner now.
我当然一直想亲眼见到Bruce，但不是这样。不是当他来的唯一原因是因为我到目前为止失败得一塌糊涂时。所以我试图通过一个简短的办公室参观来转移他的注意力。我们到了楼梯顶端的隔间。那是我，我说，快速向我悲伤的小椅子挥手。我们现在去吃饭吧。
As we walked down Sixth avenue, my girlfriend and Bruce's wife a little ahead of us, Bruce and I painfully tried to make small talk. At dinner, I finally got the experience every Bruce Campbell fan dreams about. I was hanging out with Bruce. Specifically, I was eating hummus with him. Does that sound exciting? Of course it doesn't. Everything was normal, completely un-dreamlike. And that's what made it great. We were two couples having dinner, talking about the books we had read. The only thing that skewed the night slightly towards surreality was my shaking need for a cigarette. I was holding off. I thought it might offend him. But even after, when Bruce and his wife caught me and my girlfriend frantically lighting up on the street, it wasn't weird. We all had a laugh about it.
当我们沿着第六大道走的时候，我的女朋友和Bruce的妻子在我们前面一点，Bruce和我都痛苦地试图寻找话题。在晚餐时，我终于得到了每个Bruce Campbell粉丝梦想的体验。我和Bruce混在一起。具体来说，我在和他吃鹰嘴豆泥。这听起来刺激吗？当然不。一切都很正常，完全不像是梦境。而这正是让它变得伟大的原因。我们两对夫妇在吃晚饭，谈论我们读过的书。唯一让夜晚稍微偏向超现实的是我颤抖着对香烟的需求。我忍住了。我想这可能会冒犯他。但甚至在那之后，当Bruce和他的妻子在街上看到我和我的女朋友疯狂点烟时，并不奇怪。我们都为此大笑起来。
The book finally sold tot he last editor we met that day. The one who had brought in the Bruce Campbell issue of Fangoria magazine for an autograph before introducing Bruce around to his bosses. Actually, he didn't even buy it at that house. He had to quit first and take a job at another company, and then beg his boss before he could even make a modest offer. We quickly accepted.
这本书终于卖给了那天我们见的最后一位编辑。那个在把Bruce介绍给他的老板之前，把一本《Fangoria》杂志的Bruce Campbell专刊拿去签名的人。实际上，他甚至没在那家公司买下它。他必须先辞职，去另一家公司找份工作，然后乞求他的老板，才能做出一个适度的报价。我们很快接受了。
It was a huge weight off my shoulders. It's not usual for a book to take almost two years to sell. Typically, it's more like two weeks. I was hoping that Bruce didn't know this as keenly as I did, but I could never ask him. If you're someone's literary agent, the one piece of advice you can't give them is, go get a good literary agent.
这减轻了我肩上的巨大负担。一本书卖出几乎需要两年是不常见的。通常情况下，大约两周。我希望Bruce没有像我这样敏锐地意识到这一点，但我永远无法问他。如果你是某人的文学代理人，你不能给他们的一条建议是，去找个好的文学代理人。
The day we sold the book I was on vacation with my girlfriend, whom I'd been dating for 10 years. The next day, I asked her to marry me. We can invite Bruce, I said.
卖书的那天，我正和约会了10年的女朋友度假。第二天，我向她求婚了。我们可以邀请Bruce，我说。
Hey Bruce, how you doing?
嘿Bruce，你好吗？
Greetings. Greetings. Enter. Thank you. I see you've brought goods.
问候。问候。进来。谢谢。我看到你带了东西来。
Yes, I brought a few sandwiches here. This room is pretty nice.
是的，我带了一些三明治。这房间挺好的。
It's been four years now since that first email and I'm visiting Bruce at The New Yorker Hotel in Manhattan. The book is about to come out and Bruce has come to push it with a Q&A, an autograph signing at the Fangoria Weekend of Horror.
距离那封电子邮件已经四年了，我正在曼哈顿纽约人酒店拜访Bruce。书即将出版，Bruce来到这里参加问答环节，在Fangoria恐怖周末进行签售。
Give it up for Bruce Campbell.
为Bruce Campbell鼓掌。
I'm not his agent anymore. For various reasons I've left the business, but Bruce and I have stayed in touch. Mainly because I refuse to let him go.
我不再是他的代理人了。出于各种原因，我已经离开了这个行业，但Bruce和我都保持着联系。主要是因为我拒绝让他离开。
I want everyone to stand up. Stand up. Every single one of ya. Raise your right hand. Repeat after me. I.
我希望大家站起来。站起来。你们每一个。举起右手。跟着我说。我。
I.
我。
State your name.
报上你的名字。
Comedians, huh?
喜剧演员，是吧？
Bruce is famous for antagonizing his fans, and they love it. They love him. In this room, Bruce Campbell is the biggest star in the world. His book is the most important book in the world. And I am his esteemed colleague. His former professional literary agent.
Bruce以对抗粉丝而闻名，而他们热爱这一点。他们热爱他。在这个房间里，Bruce Campbell是世界上最伟大的明星。他的书是世界上最重要的书。而我是他受人尊敬的同事。他以前的职业文学代理人。
Be better over here. Yes sir.
在这里表现得更好。是的，先生。
Are there any plans for Evil Dead IV?
有关于《鬼玩人4》的计划吗？
God, that's so weird. I've never heard that question before.
天哪，那太奇怪了。我以前从未听过这个问题。
As the convention continues, Bruce signs posters, head shots, DVDS, bootleg scripts, bared breasts, anything the fans have to offer. The line goes to the back of the room and out the door. In this crowd, there's almost a paternal sense of pride and even concern. They feel that Bruce has never had the big break he deserves.
随着大会继续，Bruce签署海报、头像、DVD、盗版剧本、裸露的乳房，粉丝们提供的任何东西。队伍排到了房间后部，一直延伸到门口。在这个人群中，几乎有一种父亲般的骄傲甚至关切。他们觉得Bruce从来没有得到他应得的重大突破。
You're brothers? Are you a Bruce Campbell fan as well?
你是兄弟？你也是Bruce Campbell的粉丝吗？
Oh, big time. Yeah. My brother and I, we're like-- he's like our idol, basically.
哦，超级粉丝。是的。我和我兄弟，我们就像——他基本上是我们的偶像。
Really?
真的吗？
We pretty much grew up watching the horror movies. That's like totally won my brother over with the whole Evil Dead series. In fact, I hope one day when I get really big in the money in the stock markets and everything, I'm going to buy a studio like, for example. And I'm to make him a star, like one of the big movies. Top notch.
我们基本上是看恐怖片长大的。那真的让我兄弟完全被整个《鬼玩人》系列迷住了。事实上，我希望有一天当我能在股市里赚大钱时，我要买一家工作室，例如。然后我要让他成为明星，比如大电影。顶级水平。
Right now I'm a freelance writer, but I used to be a literary agent. And in fact, I represented Bruce's book. I sold his book to the publishers. And I'm going this show about how four years ago when I first started talking to him about doing a book, for me I had the same impulse. It was wanting to bring him to a bigger audience. And you're saying how you'd like to--
我现在是一名自由撰稿人，但我以前是文学代理人。事实上，我代理了Bruce的书。我把他的书卖给了出版商。我要做这个节目，讲述四年前我第一次开始和他谈论写书时，对我来说，我有同样的冲动。那就是想要把他带给更多的观众。而你正在说你如何想要——
Exactly. That's awesome, man. Way to go. Definitely.
正是如此。那太棒了，伙计。干得好。绝对。
I just think it's interesting because obviously, other people feel the same way. That he deserves more exposure.
我只是认为这很有趣，因为显然，其他人也有同样的感觉。他值得更多的曝光。
He definitely deserves more. Yes. Definitely. He's really a top notch actor in reality.
他绝对值得更多。是的。绝对。他在现实中真的是一个顶级的演员。
So you start the studio. You get a Bruce Campbell vehicle going and you hire me to do the book.
所以你开了工作室。你进行一个Bruce Campbell的项目，然后你雇我来写书。
There you go. That's about it pretty much.
这就对了。基本就是这样。
And then we'll all hang out.
然后我们就一起混。
We got to hang out, definitely.
我们一定要混在一起，绝对。
This, I, realize is the paradise that all Bruce Campbell fans want to reach. They all want to hang with Bruce, but they want to earn it. They want to help him. And if the book is a hit, then I will have done exactly what that kid dreams of. What I wanted to do all along, help, and then hang out.
我意识到，这是所有Bruce Campbell粉丝想要到达的天堂。他们都想和Bruce混在一起，但他们想赢得它。他们想帮助他。如果书大卖，那么我将做到了那个孩子梦想的事情。我一直想做的事，帮忙，然后混在一起。
Finally, the convention is over. A few fans try to shadow Bruce up to his room, but he evades them. I, however, am still able to follow him through the back passages, the freight elevators, the restricted access doors. Then we run into some trouble. Bruce's key card won't open his room door and the organizer has to go down and have it reprogrammed at the desk.
最后，大会结束了。一些粉丝试图跟踪Bruce到他的房间，但他避开了他们。然而，我仍然能够穿过后面的通道、货运电梯、限制进入的门跟随他。然后我们遇到了一些麻烦。Bruce的门卡打不开他的房门，组织者不得不下去在台前重新编程。
Bruce and I stand there in the shadowy hallway locked out of his room. He seems fidgety, exposed. There's still quite a few fans roaming around and now I realize I'm one of them. I'm not his agent anymore.
Bruce和我站在阴影下的走廊里，被锁在房间外。他看起来有点坐立不安，暴露在外。仍然有相当多的粉丝在走来走去，现在我意识到我也是其中之一。我不再是他的代理人了。
When the organizer comes back with the key Bruce will go in, get changed, head out to the airport. I'll go back to my apartment, watch him on television just like I did before I ever met him. Pretty soon, I'll run out of plausible excuses to email him, to call him, to get the special treatment I've come to expect from my friend, the movie star.
当组织者拿着钥匙回来时，Bruce会进去，换好衣服，前往机场。我会回到我的公寓，像在我见到他之前一样在电视上看着他。很快，我就没法找合理的借口给他发邮件、给他打电话，以获取我从我的朋友、电影明星那里所期望的特殊待遇了。
Is there anything you won't do for a fan?
有什么事是你不会为粉丝做的吗？
They got in their head about saying these lines of dialogue.
他们脑子里总是想着说这些台词。
Like what lines?
什么台词？
Like groovy or give me some sugar or something. Those are tough just because it's hard to have the same feeling. And plus it's like, you've rented the movie. That's where it comes from. That's the original. I would just be giving you sloppy seconds.
比如“groovy”或者“给我点糖果”之类的。那些很难说，因为很难有同样的感觉。而且就像，你租了那部电影。那是台词的出处。那是原创。我只是给你吃剩的。
Would you say groovy?
你会说“groovy”吗？
No.
不。
Come on.
来吧。
No.
不。
For your old literary agent.
为你以前的文学代理人。
I said no.
我说不。
John Hodgman lives in New York. Bruce Campbell's book is If Chins Could Kill: Confessions of a B-Movie Actor.
John Hodgman住在纽约。Bruce Campbell的书是《如果下巴能杀人：B级片演员的自白》。
[MUSIC-"THEME TO SECRET AGENT MAN"]
[音乐-“秘密特工主题曲”]
Act Three, Airel Sharon, Shimon Peres, David Ben Gurion, and Me!
第三幕，阿里尔·沙龙，希蒙·佩雷斯，大卫·本·古里安，还有我！
Well, you've heard about a number of different kinds of dreams in today's program. There is also a kind of dream that we have to protect ourselves from seeing who we really are.
好吧，你在今天的节目中听到了许多不同种类的梦想。也有一种梦想，我们需要保护自己，以免看到我们真正是谁。
December 3, 1986, Wednesday. Another fascinating day in the life of Adam Davidson. I have a math test tomorrow. I'm going to school early to tutor a girl in my class for the aforementioned test. My math class, a joint precalculus and calculus class, consists mainly of seniors not especially interested in learning. I guess that I'm the quote "class expert" unquote, in that I always do the math problems which no one else can. And for this, I'm disliked. I guess that because I apply myself, think clearly, and do a little work, as well as some intelligence helping out, I am a geek. In truth, I am far from it.
1986年12月3日，星期三。Adam Davidson生活中的又一个迷人日子。我明天有个数学考试。我早早去学校给班上的一个女孩补习刚才提到的考试。我的数学课，一门联合预微积分和微积分课程，主要由对学习不太感兴趣的三年级学生组成。我想我是所谓的“班级专家”，因为我总是能做别人做不到的数学题。因此，我不受欢迎。我想是因为我努力学习，思考清晰，做了一点工作，加上一些智力帮助，我成了极客。事实上，我远非如此。
When you first read that to yourself, when you first saw it, your reaction was?
当你第一次对自己读到这个，当你第一次看到它时，你的反应是？
It was pure horror.
纯粹的恐惧。
Recently, Adam Davidson, an occasional contributor to our program, found his old high school diaries. Adam's mom is Israeli, his dad is American. Adam grew up in New York. His body was in New York. His brain, as the diaries reveal, was somewhere else entirely.
最近，Adam Davidson，我们节目的偶尔撰稿人，发现了他的高中日记。Adam的妈妈是以色列人，爸爸是美国人。Adam在纽约长大。他的身体在纽约。他的大脑，正如日记所揭示的，完全在另一个地方。
I remember when I was writing it, I remember very clearly. Although I don't say this in the diary that it was very clear to me that this was the diary of the future prime minister of Israel. Me. That I would one day be prime minister. And it would be very important for history, for people to know the deep thoughts of a young Zionist as he prepared his way to lead his nation.
我记得我写它的时候，记得非常清楚。尽管我在日记里没这么说，但很清楚的是，这是一位以色列未来总理的日记。我。我有一天会成为总理。对于历史来说，对于人们了解一位年轻的犹太复国主义者在准备领导他的国家时的深层思想，这将非常重要。
Now, our regular listeners here in This American Life might remember that you've been on our program describing your experience in Israeli army summer camp.
现在，我们《美国生活》的常客可能记得你曾经在我们的节目中描述过你在以色列军队夏令营的经历。
That was right before I started writing this diary.
那是在我开始写这本日记之前。
Read me another.
再给我读一段。
Sure. Let's see.
好的。看看。
There's so much wrong with Jews in Israel that I'm going to have a job ahead of me. One thing is the lack of any strong Jewish identity among most Jews. This attitude sickens me. You Jews of the world, stop worrying about money and well being. I do not know what exactly I'll do. But if this situation continues when I'm a bit older, then watch out world Jewry, here comes Adam.
以色列的犹太人有很多问题，我将面临一项艰巨的工作。其中之一是大多数犹太人缺乏任何强大的犹太认同感。这种态度让我感到恶心。你们世界各地的犹太人，别再担心钱和福利了。我不知道我具体要做什么。但如果这种情况持续到我再大一点的时候，那么世界犹太人要注意了，Adam来了。
And "watch out world Jewry, here comes Adam" was all in capital letters.
而且“世界犹太人要注意了，Adam来了”全部是大写字母。
Wow. It's interesting that you actually are addressing a readership.
哇。有趣的是你实际上是在面对读者。
I know. That's what kind of amazing.
我知道。这太令人惊奇了。
And that readership is world Jewry.
而且那些读者是世界犹太人。
Yeah. The Jews of the world will one day read this book and will say, if he knew this at 16, how could I be living so badly?
是的。世界各地的犹太人有一天会读到这本书，并会说，如果他在16岁时就知道这一点，我怎么能活得这么糟糕？
Can I ask you to just read one of the passages where you talk about Israel?
我可以请你读一下你谈论以色列的段落吗？
Sure. Let's see. I mean I have this thing from January 4, 1987.
当然。看看。我的意思是，我有1987年1月4日的这段东西。
I memorized "The Hope", Hatikva, which is the Israeli National Anthem a few minutes ago. That will help me in Israel. I find that really amazing that here I am, the future prime minister of Israel and what are the things I need? Oh, God, I need to know the national anthem. I'll probably be called upon to recite that at some point.
我刚才背诵了《希望》，Hatikva，也就是以色列国歌。那会在以色列帮到我。我觉得那真的很神奇，我在这里，以色列的未来总理，我需要什么东西？噢，上帝，我需要知道国歌。我可能在某个时候需要背诵那个。
Or they'll be a ball game or something, you'll need to stand up and sing it.
或者会有球赛之类的，你需要站起来唱它。
Right, exactly.
对，完全正确。
At 16, I had such an inflated sense of myself. There was so much going on in my life then that I can remember and I wasn't recording it. Instead, I was creating this ridiculous fantasy of I'm not just a 16 year old kid who's having crushes and a hopeless geek who can't get a girl to kiss him. And being scared and confused about growing old. I'm the future prime minister of Israel and everything goes through that.
16岁时，我对自己有一种极度膨胀的感觉。那时我的生活中发生了很多事，我可以记得，但我没有记录。相反，我创造了这个荒谬的幻想：我不只是一个16岁的小孩，有着迷恋对象，一个无法让女孩吻他的无可救药的极客。害怕和困惑于变老。我是以色列的未来总理，一切都通过那个滤镜。
But I don't know.
但我不知道。
But maybe keeping a diary where one tells the truth, maybe that's a luxury of being a certain kind of person in a certain kind of situation. Maybe other people in another kind of situation need to actually make up a little fantastic.
但也许坚持写一本讲真话的日记，那可能是特定情况下特定人的奢侈。也许处于另一种情况下的其他人需要真正地编造一点幻想。
Yeah. I didn't have much angst about being the future prime minister of Israel. I was very calm and confident and comfortable with it. And I had so much angst about every other aspect of my life. So I now see it as just kind of-- maybe it was a good solution. It was a good way to deal with what I was going through. To have this space where I could just be one of the greats.
是的。对于成为以色列的未来总理，我没什么焦虑。我非常冷静、自信并对此感到舒适。而我对自己生活中的所有其他方面都有很多焦虑。所以我现在把它视为一种——也许这是一个好办法。这是处理我所经历的事情的一个好方法。拥有这个空间，我可以成为伟人之一。
I wonder what the 16 year old Adam Davidson would feel in knowing that finally, an audience of a million people was getting some of the reading from this diary.
我想知道16岁的Adam Davidson在知道终于有100万听众读到这本日记的内容时会是什么感觉。
I think this would feel so small to that 16 year old. This would feel so nothing. This would be so unimportant.
我觉得这对那个16岁的人来说太小了。这感觉简直什么都不是。这会很不重要。
Being on the radio?
在广播上？
Being on the radio, a million people. What's a million people? I mean, we're talking about history. We're talking about sweeping changes. I'm pretty sure that he would be thoroughly unimpressed.
在广播上，100万人。100万人是什么？我的意思是，我们在谈论历史。我们在谈论彻底的变革。我很确定他会完全不为所动。
And Adam, what would the 16 year old you think of you now?
那么Adam，16岁的你会怎么看现在的你？
I think he'd be really disappointed. I think he'd be really sad.
我觉得他会很失望。我觉得他会很伤心。
Because you're not the prime minister of Israel?
因为你不是以色列总理？
Yeah, because I just have such a small life.
是的，因为我过着这么渺小的生活。
I mean I remember I was very disappointed and very sad about my parents. I was reading biographies, of course, of all the prime ministers of Israel. And I would just think about my parents and just think, how do you wake up every day knowing that your actions won't affect millions of people? How is that enough motivation? Just to have your petty little craft and your petty little family and your small little apartment. It just seemed pathetic. I mean, they have the kind of life that, I mean basically, I want for myself.
我的意思是，我记得我对自己父母感到非常失望和悲伤。我当时当然在读以色列所有总理的传记。我会想到我的父母，只是想，你每天醒来怎么能知道你的行为不会影响数百万人？怎么能有足够的动力？仅仅为了你那微不足道的技艺，你那微不足道的家庭和你那渺小的公寓。这看起来真可悲。我的意思是，他们过着那种，我基本上想要的生活。
What you're saying though, is that the 16 year old you would be cringing at your 30 year old version just as your 30 year old version is cringing at the 16.
不过，你说的是，16岁的你会对30岁的版本感到畏缩，正如你30岁的版本对16岁的感到畏缩一样。
Yeah, that's very true. He would be very, very disgusted if he heard this radio piece. It would seem like I had settled in a pathetic way.
是的，那非常真实。如果他听到这期广播节目，他会非常、非常厌恶。这看起来就像我以一种可悲的方式妥协了。
Adam Davidson in Los Angeles.
Adam Davidson在洛杉矶。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Paul McCarthy. Original music in our story on FoxxJazell by TRS-80. That's Deb, Kent, and Jay.
好吧，我们的节目今天由Jonathan Goldstein和我本人制作，Alex Blumberg，Wendy Dorr和Starlee Kine参与。高级制作人Julie Snyder。Elizabeth Meister运行我们的网站。Todd Bachmann和Paul McCarthy提供制作帮助。FoxxJazell故事中的原创音乐由TRS-80提供。那是Deb，Kent和Jay。
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago 312-832-3380. Or visit our website where you can also listen to our programs for free at www.thisamericanlife.org. Don't forget those MP3s.
要购买本节目的磁带，请拨打我们在芝加哥WBEZ的电话312-832-3380。或者访问我们的网站，您也可以在www.thisamericanlife.org免费收听我们的节目。别忘了那些MP3。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who explains himself this way.
WBEZ管理监督由Torey Malatia负责，他是这样解释自己的。
Last couple of jobs I've had a big problem with using the women's restroom.
过去两份工作我在使用女厕所方面遇到了很大的问题。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。